I watched this great documentary once a
called Hitman Hart and was about Bret
Hart who was the most famous Canadian in
the world for awhile and he was,
he was a world wide wrestling federation
wrestler,
you know,
and he was a good guy and he came from
this famous family of wrestlers who all
came from Alberta.
I think there were seven brothers who
were wrestlers and seven sisters and all
of the sisters married wrestlers and
they were all offspring.
Children of Stu Hart,
who,
who was a wrestling impresario like 40
years ago.
And it was,
it was such a cool documentary because I
was always wondering why in the world
did people watch wrestling and,
and,
and believe it,
you know,
believe it.
Do you believe movies when you go watch
them?
It's like,
that's a hard question to answer while
you're there.
You do.
And so if you're watching wrestling and
you're a wrestling fan,
do you believe it?
Well,
it isn't a matter of belief.
It's a matter of being engaged in a
drama and there are different levels of
drama.
Right?
So let's say worldwide Wrestling
Federation drama is not the most
sophisticated form of drama.
Okay?
But I'm not being not being a smart Alec
when I'm saying that there is drama of
different sophistication for different
people and that's also why religious
truths exists at multiple levels
simultaneously.
Right?
There's got to be something in it for
everyone and that's a hard belief
system.
That's a hard system to put together.
Something for the unbelievably
sophisticated and something for the
common person.
Okay.
So we have wrestling and Brett Hart was
a good guy and he fell into the
archetype of being a good guy and that's
partly what the.
What the story's about.
It was a bit too much for him,
but I'm.
One of the things that he,
he laid out so carefully was because he
figured that a hundred and $20 million
people knew him,
something like that and that everywhere
he went,
he was treated like a hero.
And he found that quite a bit of quite a
burden.
And as you can imagine,
if you think about it,
but he portrayed what was happening in
the wrestling ring as classic good
against evil but not conceptualized in
disgust,
right?
Embodied,
fought out,
acted out,
you know,
like,
like the,
like thor and the hulk,
except like right in front of you.
And so,
well that's exactly this sort of thing.
I mean,
look,
we could consider hockey more
sophisticated than wrestling perhaps.
And that has,
as I said,
I'm not being a critic of these.
I am not being critically minded about
these things.
I understand their purpose and I would
highly recommend that documentary.
It's a brilliant documentary,
but this is,
it's the same thing.
It's a Silver Cup,
right?
It's like there's the hero of the team
that's the hero of the teams.
You know,
here's something cool if you're.
The founder of the Toronto Blue Jays are
the Toronto Maple leafs.
Of course this hardly ever happens to
you if you're a fan of the Toronto Maple
leafs because they always lose.
But,
but,
but if you're watching a game and your
team wins and we take your testosterone
levels,
then they went up and if you watched the
Toronto Maple leafs and they lost and
you're a fan than your testosterone
levels go.
So that's pretty damn funny,
you know,
I mean really don't you see how deeply
instantiated this as in people?
I mean,
it bloody well alters your biochemistry,
like your,
your,
your testosterone levels.
It's all my team lost,
you know,
it's like there'll be no,
there'll be nothing in it for the wife
tonight,
you know?
Oh yeah.